i am honored and delighted to accept the
studyboard on behalf of everyone
in teradek and amirimon i would like to
thank the academy members and the
committee for recognizing this
achievement
it is not every day that an engineer
gets credit we have to be thankful to
maxwell marconi and all the scientific
giants that made this remarkable
technology possible
in teradek i'd like to thank danish
schieffner that designed
the first and every bolt since 2012.
dr ilya essinen for doing some dark
magic to make it all work
richard billett for testing and
supporting countless crews on set
marius vanderwaat for overseeing all of
engineering over many generations
and greg smokler for always representing
the way
actual people actually use the product
in amamon
i'd like to thank dr zv reznik uri
kananich
ron yugev guy dorman guy dar
and aharon kamaji for always taking care
of us most of all
i would like to thank the customers the
tens of thousands of camera
steadicam and drone operators the ids
and first ics that helped us build a
product that has
impacted the industry so much maxwell
would be proud